hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm going to
explain a 2020 american science fiction
and action movie called bloodshot
the movie begins with maureen ray
garrison and his team who are
undertaking an operation in kenya they
break into a house where the main target
is hiding eliminating all of his men
easily until rey reaches a room the main
target has his rifle aimed at a hostage
and forces rey to lower his weapon
he attempts to negotiate with the
terrorist and manages to trick the
target into moving his rifle
using this opportunity ray grabs his
pistol and shoots the target to death
mission accomplished and the marines
return to italy where rey's wife gina
has been waiting for her lover the
couple immediately head over to amalfi
coast and spend a comfortable evening
together
ray tells gina despite all the scars he
received and all the operations he went
on he always comes home
the next day ray is left alone in the
hotel room when some home invaders
suddenly break in and attack him
he tries to fight them and manages to
eliminate all the invaders killing them
on the spot however when he tries to run
away he meets martin axe who
incapacitates him with a tranquilizer
ray later wakes up tied to a chair while
martin is interrogating him forcing him
to leak the source who tipped him off
about the hostages in kenya earlier ray
insists that he doesn't know but martin
brings out a captive gina threatens him
that his man will kill her if he doesn't
comply
he keeps telling the bad guy that he
doesn't know so martin decides to shoot
gina in the head with a six inches nail
gun
ray is furious and swears with liam
neeson's golden phrase that he will find
and kill him
he tells martin that he should kill him
while he can
martin takes the advice and shoots him
in the face
ray is magically revived and awakens in
a testing facility of rst
he meets dr emile harding the man behind
the project bloodshot that gives rey a
second chance in the world and his
assistant kt
ray can't remember anything even his
name
dr harding explains that ray was killed
and his body was donated by the us
military because nobody claimed his body
he tells him that rst is part of the us
military that develops stuff to make
soldiers faster and stronger
rey's body has been filled with
microbots called nanites that act as
blood substitutes and allow his body to
regenerate from every wound applied to
his body turns out that harding lost one
of his arms when he was young and he
replaced it with a steel arm with
stronger power he then introduces rey to
other soldiers with rst implants
kt who now breathes through a respirator
there are tibs who has a camera
implanted that allows him to see
everything through it and jimmy dalton
ex-navy seal with prosthetic legs
implanted in his body
after that ray returns to his room and
gets some rest
later that night he begins to remember
his past causing him to wake up from his
sleep he decides to test out his new
body and discovers that he has
superhuman strength as well allowing him
to crack a concrete column in several
punches he then sees kt who demonstrates
his ability to hold his breath as long
as she wants in the water ray interacts
with her and she encourages him to focus
on the future and forget the past
as they share a drink together rey
suddenly remembers all the events just
before he was killed by martin
kt tries to calm him down but he ignores
her and immediately heads out to find
the killer
raised nanitz manages to scan through
search platforms and hack into the
interpol network which allow ray to
discover martin's location
harding warns him and orders him to come
back but he can't be stopped as he's
already hot on martin's trail
using the knowledge he gets from the
internet he flies a private jet to
budapest where martin and his men are
doing their operation
when the cars reach the tunnel ray
deliberately crashes a truck towards
them blocking their way out he
eliminates all the bodyguards one by one
their bullets cause no effect towards
him as his body manages to rapidly
regenerate some severe gunshot wounds
martin recognizes ray and attempts to
run away from the car while ray keeps
knocking out all of his men easily he
eventually corners martin and he starts
begging for his life
martin tells him that harding is
manipulating him but ray doesn't care
and immediately shoots martin to death
in the morning ray drives to a place
where kt dalton and tips have been
waiting for him he is brought back to
rst and gets himself charged suddenly
dalton comes in to tell him that gina is
not really dead and reveals that rey is
actually a toy soldier that is being
used repeatedly by harding to kill
specific people he doesn't like
dalton then commences the memory wiping
procedure which makes ray forget
everything he has gone through
on the other side it is revealed that
harding organizes everything from the
hostage situation to raise capture to be
replayed again and again in his mind
what's different in each sequence is the
shooter's face
this time harding's i.t expert eric
alters the man's face into nick barish's
face who used to be harding's colleague
kt suddenly shows up and claims that she
has had enough with the operation as she
knows rey is being used against his free
will
harding promises her that this will be
the last one and orders her to prepare
the real world scenario for rey
she has no choice and unreluctantly
obeys him
rey wakes up and goes through the exact
scene as before but this time he sees
burish as the man who killed his wife
as usual harding and his team monitor
him from the office and pretend to be
concerned he manages to trace and locate
boris's hideout and immediately flies to
london
eric also manages to hack into the
house's cctv cameras allowing them to
track burish men's movements
ray allows himself to be captured by the
bodyguards to get himself inside the
hideout burish i.t expert wilfred
wiggins has prepared an emp to use
against him if necessary which harding
in his men's spot through the
surveillance cameras
however the device needs time to be
charged until 100 while rey starts
knocking out everyone and is getting
closer to boris rome
harding realizes this and orders his toy
soldier to abort the mission but rey
mutes him and keeps moving forward
rey eventually reaches the room and
immediately kills burish before the emp
is fully charged
in the other room wiggins hits the emp
button instantly knocking out all
electric power within a 20 mile radius
as well as temporarily shutting ray down
he then wakes ray up with a powerful
electrical charge
he tells ray that he was forced to work
for burish but he actually wants to help
him the marine then informs wigans about
experiencing the same memory over and
over again but with a different face for
each killer this makes wiggins figure
out that harding has been using him to
wipe out every defector of rst
ray realizes that gina is alive but
wiggins worries that if he goes looking
for her harding will capture him reset
his memories and put wiggins face on the
shooter's body next time
ray insists on going there and he gives
the i t expert a sample of his nana's
blood ordering him to figure out how it
works
after that rey takes barish vintage car
and heads over to gina's place
he finally meets gina and thinks that
they are still married however she
reveals that she has moved on and
married someone else
when asked the last time they saw each
other she tells him that they have split
up on mutual terms since five years ago
the heartbroken ray drives away but
suddenly gets hit by a truck
dalton then shows up and shoots him
ray runs away but is chased by tibs and
dalton
after a long run the superhuman steals a
rifle from the police officer and starts
shooting dalton
realizing that bullets are useless he
runs away again and dalton pursues him
but ray manages to get him to get hit by
a truck that shatters his prosthetic
legs tibb shows up and manages to stab
ray with a special weapon which
immediately shuts him down
on the other side harding orders kt to
eliminate wiggins she disobeys but she
cannot do anything as harding has full
control over her ability to breathe and
makes her suffocate long story short
katie finds wiggins and his men
somewhere in london where she knocks
them out with her fighting skill and
then takes wiggins away
harding tries to talk to rey in a
virtual world where the superhuman
expresses his anger toward harding the
scientist acts as though he did what was
necessary and did what was right for ray
he then returns rey back to the rst lab
to extract the nanos
kt returns and tells harding that the
i.t expert has escaped
panicked he cancels the extraction
process and immediately orders eric to
rebuild the sequence for wiggins
rey is put into the hostage simulation
again but this time kt intervenes and
orders wiggins to hack into rst server
harding is furious and tries to shut
katie down but she reveals that she got
wiggins to remove his access to her
breathing implant harding orders dawson
and tibs to chase after ray who manages
to break free
wiggins locates the company's server
room and orders kt to destroy it which
she does
dalton confronts ray and both of them
then engage in a fight causing them to
fall off the window a few moments later
tibbs comes to help his partner it's a
two versus one situation and somehow ray
still manages to over strengthen
tibs eventually falls to his death as
dalton tries to break down the elevator
ray then grabs dalton and both of them
free-falling while he punches him to the
ground
harling shows up in the street and
shoots ray with a grenade launcher it
explodes but he withstands the explosion
and starts to regenerate wiggins
discovers that the nanites are running
low and he won't recover if he takes
another hit luckily ray manages to catch
the next grenade and cuts it down to the
core
he approaches hartling and drops the
grenade blowing both of them up
long story short wiggins recovers rey's
body and revives him from death again he
then reprograms the nanites within his
body to increase the durability of the
microbots together with kt the trio
begin their new journey as a team
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching